Kink and I did a movie together back in
the day it was 2002.
and um we actually have a clip for
contacts roll it oh my God it's a 2G
buy-in Winner Takes all rules are there
are no rules I'm down
[Music]
yes Cameron
by the way I heard you said that like
something about height and Cameron it's
something like you wished you were
taller when you were with her oh yeah oh
my God I'm like welcome to my world oh
yeah like when your best friend is a
gazelle and an Amazon but you're you no
I'm really tiny I'm only five yeah three
I say five four but you know I'm lying
about an inch
three and three quarters you aren't
that's me that's
hold on I feel like Drew is my sister
from another parallel universe and I've
always felt that way I told her that I
do
it's funny okay but it's back to back
the hair wins
[Applause]
I I feel like I haven't had as many
parallels so much fun I know right do
people ever say when you talk they don't
really hear anything
they just
I hear words
aren't you dreamy
[Applause]
I when I first I say how I first met you
please we were I was sitting on Melrose
Avenue on the concrete outside of a hair
salon waiting for the bleach to kick in
and Drew walks by and I go oh no Drew
um I love you you don't know me but
maybe I don't know one day you might and
and I did a book report on little girl
lost in seventh grade and you made me
feel less alone and I just I I love
knowing that you're in the world walking
at the same time as me and it was I was
just like wow I love la
oh
I got a whole new book right now I I do
want to write another book actually from
a whole new perspective I'll do a book
report
I feel like I have so much in common
with you and actually I have a question
because I I um like it it's I know we're
here but I I when I asked the question
it's like popcorn for me personally to
learn Lauren
I could have really hooked you up
I am
um is that your copy of the book yes
look I brought it
dead
in seventh grade I did my first real
book report I chose little girl lost and
my teacher was like are you okay
yes I'm fine
um I became oh thank you Veda thank you
so much
now we're complete thank you I I wanted
to start like when I had my kids all of
a sudden I couldn't play anyone else I
think I needed to be my kid's mom like
that mission felt so clear
and when the show came along and the
opportunity one of the things I didn't
want to do was like be like I was born
today and I have no back story I
understand that completely
and I think you do an incredible job of
it also because you're such a lovable
person and you do have a backstory and
you haven't hit it and that's another
thing we have in common because I'm I
know my kids are going to know all of me
either by what I tell them by what they
hear out of my mouth or what they see
that I've already said before they were
around that's the thing and I didn't
know when I was younger and I was
partying and having and I won't I don't
feel bad about the narrative like I I
even this craziest stuff I experienced
like okay both of us partied like
starting at week nine yeah which is like
I know it's like didn't know I was ever
gonna have kids yeah no I couldn't
picture it right no me neither and my
parents split up so I didn't think that
families stayed together and I didn't
think I would ever have kids and I just
sort of lived you know when you're young
and you're just like immortal and you're
just a hedonist having the best time
ever I don't even mix Tylenol and Advil
now
oh how the pendulum swings
what can I tell myself
when I'm afraid my kids will do some of
the stuff I did
great question
hum
[Music]